Andrea wrote in saying people often have
opinions about things they know little
about are there any things in particular
that really bother you when some some 10
Pines without any clue for whatever
reason like diet and medical stuff I get
pretty irritated when people just say
completely matter-of-factly in black and
white terms X or Y about medical or diet
stuff when they really don't know about
it or haven't researched it I mean
certainly I encounter a lot of people
who because of what I do want to talk
about politics with me and I guess I
sort of find it annoying when people
regurgitate something is fact that
they're actually completely clueless
about but are convinced that they know
about but I'm sort of used to that
because a lot of the guests we interview
seem to have that exact same problem uh
also the other one I find annoying and
this is I'm not a parent so I don't know
exactly why it strikes a chord with me
but when people give parenting advice in
a completely definitive black-and-white
way like if they know what the right
thing is to do they tell another parent
you're doing the wrong thing and often
they don't really have a clue about
anything that one bothers me and I I am
NOT someone who is a parent or or ever
really had any particular experiences
where someone tried telling me what to
do and then my parents said now he's our
son or whatever I don't have any
particular experience from history that
would make me particularly triggered or
reactive to that but that I find really
pretty annoying those are a few I don't
know if you have any Pat were like when
you hear some opinion or people comment
and you recognize they don't know
anything that it really angers you in
particular well politics is a big one
and you touched on it because regardless
of how educated you are you can still
have an opinion you're still entitled to
that so when you're someone who like
follows the news and is like well
educated in the subject matter and
you're kinda up against someone who just
is regurgitating talking points that
they've heard on CNN yeah I mean that
can be awfully frustrating I think along
the same lines attitudes towards mental
illness and poverty and homelessness
that are completely disconnected from
the real world people are only poor
because they just haven't decided to
stop being poor yet and everybody can
pull themselves up by their bootstraps
factually untrue
people live their entire lives with
limited empathy for people who are poor
or homeless because they just think
everybody who's poor homeless a deserves
it and or be could change it at any time
it's just not true and we're doing some
kind of drug to you can throw that in
there too and absolutely an end mental
illness and drug addiction as not being
considered as serious as just like a
physical illness you usually don't blame
people for having diabetes uh maybe it's
a bad example because depending on what
type of diabetes you talking to it can
be related to diet but in the same way
that it's weird to be angry at someone
because they get the flu uh being angry
at someone because they're mentally ill
or not reacting in sort of an empathetic
sympathetic way uh and the same thing as
far as poverty goes people who are who
are mean to poor people or homeless
people I I truly just don't understand
that it really rubs me the wrong way and
they could be well meaning to they could
just be too simplistic and how they
phrase things and it gets interpreted as
them just being insensitive absolutely
so I I think those are a few of them and
then also I mean just on a personal note
when people come to me knowing nothing
about journalism or the production of
programs and tell me exactly what it is
that I should be doing I welcome all
advice from everybody in what I do
anybody I don't care how educated you
are I don't care who you are I don't
care about any identity particulars if
you come to me with an idea about the
show I'm absolutely interested in
willing to listen what I don't like is
when people come to me and with
absolutely no knowledge or basis for
these beliefs at all tell me in the in
in black and white terms X that I'm
doing is wrong and why is how I should
be doing it and they're absolutely
clueless and I sort of try to explain to
them why something's not practical or
realistic they don't care they're right
they know although they've never sat in
front of a camera spoken in front of
microphone been around a camera been
around anything journalism related
etcetera uh and and are um defiant in
that they know but I don't know that can
be pretty annoying